In this video, I'm going to be breaking
down the second part of copy instincts.
Uh, if you didn't, go back and watch the
very first video so that a lot of this
will make sense to you. Like I said
before, I believe that this copy
instincts is
if copy blocks, which is another video
on this channel, is like the foundation.
This is like the level two version and
it is so so so so powerful. It's going
to allow you to write amazing hooks,
write amazing ads, um, and actually
utilize AI in a much more effective way.
So, let's just get in into it. Uh, by
the way, if you don't know who I am, my
name is Luke E-ha. And myself and my
business partner, Mario Castelli and I
are copywriters. We've each done a lot
of money with our copy. We have a bunch
of creative strategists inside of our
community. And this community is growing
every single day. Uh, we work with
people who uh work with brands like
this. Here's a bunch of wins. I think
this document will be posted below this
video, so you can check some of these
things out. We do a horrible job at
recording our wins, but uh here's a good
little sampling of it. Okay, so let's
break into copy and so the first thing
is I want to go and do a review and
recap of a lot of the things that we
covered last time. Even if you watch
that first video, watch this review and
recap because the way that I say it this
time may land something for you. The
stuff that we're talking about here is a
little bit tricky and complicated. So,
you're going to have to review it a
couple different times. So, use this
opportunity to to kind of get a refresh
on what it is that we're talking about.
and hear it in a different way because
it'll start to land more clearly. So,
copy instincts, we said these are about
the questions that you ask yourself or
AI. And if you remember, we figured
these out by analyzing, you know, over
400 plus hours of copy review that my
business partner and I have done and
then extracting all the patterns. And
what we notice separates us from other
people who are on the call is not
necessarily skills because when we ask
them questions, uh, they would be able
to give us the right answers. So, they
already knew the right answers. The
problem is they weren't asking
themselves the right questions
consistently and habitually enough to
generate the answers for themselves. And
the same thing is true with AI. Uh AI is
is can do many things. It's a very
powerful tool. But in many cases, it's
limited by the amount of questions that
you ask. You can ask very crazy
questions and it will give you
extraordinary answers. Okay? But it
depends again on the types of questions
that you're asking it. So copy instincts
are about the questions that you ask
yourself. And we bracketed these
questions into three categories. what
you see, what you attract, get attracted
to, and what you make. So to simplify
that, these are uh copy instincts is a
way that you perceive when you look at a
piece of copy, you're able to see
details in it. When you're trying to
create copy, you know, like kind of the
direction of where you want to arrive,
like you have a north star to go to. And
then when you actually sit down to
generate it, you know the tools and
techniques to actually get to that north
star. Okay? And we're going to make that
really concrete in this video. Copy
instincts operate at all levels of copy.
a big idea mechanism, ad copy, hooks and
headlines. And you cannot get here from
simply learning more concepts, right?
Because it's deeper and underneath all
of it. The other thing we talked about
is that it's not it's probability and
not truth. So copy instincts and things
that I'm talking about work in general,
but market always changes and there's
always specific nuances and I never
think that I'm smarter than the market.
And we also talk about don't be a nerd.
Okay? So that actually applies across
everything I'm talking about. This is
not a formula. This is not a rubric or a
template. If that's what you're looking
for, great. We have those. But I'm
trying to talk to people who want to
practice the skill and craft of being
extraordinary marketers, right? And so,
it's not necessarily a template that
you're going to follow. Here's a
definition of a copy instinct uh that I
think is really important.
And these are the the perceptual
instincts and the attractor instincts
that we talked about in the previous
video. In this video, we're going to
talk about the making the generator
instincts. Okay? But just to remind you,
the stuff that helps you to see clearly
are things like copy blocks, right? So
you can easily analyze where there are
copy blocks, where they're missing. Uh
you have interception, metacognition or
sematic awareness. This is basically the
ability to look at a piece of copy and
notice what are the elements in the copy
that stand out to you. They literally
give you a physical reaction in your
body so that you can it gives you a
signal that something may be interesting
there. And the other one is what I call
gray verse color, boring versus
interesting, right? So, if you're really
good at tracking your body and your
physical sensations, right, or even your
thoughts as you read a piece of copy,
it'll allow you to start to identify
what is boring and what is interesting
within the copy, which is really
important. The attractor instincts are
basically um
that these are the one north star. So,
what it is is that you look at these
different elements on here. So,
spokesperson, mechanism, ingredients,
features, delivery mechanism, packaging,
branding, mental association, zeitgeist.
And what you're trying to do is you're
trying to take all of these elements and
play around with different possibilities
for the ingredients, for the delivery
mechanism, etc. until you come across
some combination of those that is really
unique and novel really preeminent which
means it's the most it's the best it's
the first it's the of anything that
you're using things like associations in
magical thinking so we talked about the
PDRN example right so uh we humans are
kind of associative creatures we don't
think extremely logically so we make
associations one thing to another even
if they're not a logical connection we
kind of uh feel that way and then some
of these other elements and what you're
looking for is you're looking for um
some combination of of these different
elements that maximize these concepts,
right? With paying attention to the
trade-offs and then they're they're all
in direction to one north star. Okay,
the north star is what would have to be
true about the world for this to be the
best possible solution. Infinite budget,
infinite time. Um you basically create
that worldview and then you argue for
that worldview. You're not selling the
product. You're not even selling the
outcome. you are selling the worldview
and the outcome of the product falls out
of that. Okay, it's a little bit of a
slight reframe, but this is super
important. Okay, you're basically making
an argument for a type of worldview that
would have your product be the
inevitable best platonic ideal solution,
right? That's kind of the frame of where
you're coming from. And then of course
you can adjust uh based on compliance,
based on what's obviously true um based
on your brand, based on you can still
make damaging emissions like but that's
kind of the northstar of what you're
going to right here's a couple different
definitions that I encourage you. You
can get access to this document by
opting into my email list and all other
documents and I encourage you to just
kind of look through this. Right? Again
the core idea is you have an attractor
that's drawing to you to making your
product the platonic ideal of a
solution. When you know that it's your
north star, then you can use all the
following moves to help you get there.
What's most unique about this product
that can't be said about anyone else?
How can we make those elements
preeminent, a category of one? How can
we borrow associations and magical
thinking to make those elements more
pristine? How can we be more make this
specific unique combination, the perfect
combination at our current time and
place? How can we make all of this
coherent? And that's what we did with
the PDRN. I encourage you to watch the
last video. We discovered that PDRN
compound plus gold micro needling were
the most unique things about the
product. Right? I'm not saying that
couldn't be said about anyone else but
you know it it's the most unique thing
about this product. So then we started
looking at how can we make those
elements preeminent right so PDRN is the
star ingredient um what is about uh
where does PDRN come from? It comes from
salmon. So, how can we make salmon
themselves this uh preeminent fish,
right? Meaning the most rejuvenating
fish, right? And so, and we we're
borrowing associations of salmon like
swimming upstream and and bruising and
battering its skin and then rejuvenating
itself, right? We're borrowing all of
that sort of like mental real estate to
make the argument that PDRN is the best,
right? Because really what happened is
somebody gave us this product and said,
"Market it, right? But we want to act as
if somebody sat down, the most genius
scientist in the world with infinite
budget was like, "How could I make the
absolute best skincare thing?" Well, let
me think about it. What animal in the
wild is the most rejuvenating? Oh, it's
the the salmon, right? And therefore,
I'm going to extract the salmon, right?
We're sort of reverse engineering it in
that way. The next thing we did is we
looked at even more associations in
magical thinking. So, we looked at
different types of salmon, right? and we
identify that there's something called
the Korean cherry salmon which again
just has such strong connotations. Now,
I don't know if they're actually derived
from Korean cherry salmon. And if that's
not the case, then you probably don't
want to say it. But just as a teaching
example, if this is true of something
that you can say, obviously, this is
going to be a lot stronger than a
regular type of salmon, right? And it's
only because of the associations of
Korean and cherry. Nothing has changed
about the salmon, right? It's the same
fish underneath it, but these
associations are carrying a lot of
weight. Uh and then the other thing is
like gold micro needling and and we add
that and basically make an argument that
unless you have gold micro needling plus
PDR in compound this doesn't work. Okay.
And then we make all of that coherent
into making one final argument. Here's a
couple of other examples that were
pulled directly from our A-lister
feedback call. So this is a guy who's
basically selling a premium olive oil.
But if you just say it's premium olive
oil like it's cold pressed and high
polyphenol extra virgin everyone says
those exact words. So what we try to
look for is what's the most unique
aspect of this product. And we found
that these olive trees grow on what was
the UN no man's land in Cypress, a
buffer zone that's been completely
untouched for 35 years. Right? Then we
basically made the argument that because
um there's no chemicals or anything
else. Uh we actually make the argument
that it's the hardest toughest soil to
grow in, right? There's nothing on it
that's ever grown. Therefore, they
produce the highest polyphenols ever
because it's actually the toughest type
of um soil to grow in, right? They fight
harder in the virgin soils. They produce
more polyphenols as a stress response.
It's more potent because of the
adversity, right? And then if we look at
Cypress, we could even start to look at
what kind of what are the associations
with Cypress, right? And how could we
make it feel like this land of struggle,
right? And therefore, we have all these
associations of like this is this
pristine no man's land almost barren,
right? that nobody's even touched. No
one's ever grown on it. It's never been
fertilized or tilled. It's the toughest,
hardest soil ever imaginable. Therefore,
the olive oil you get from there is 10
to 15 times more potent. Right? It's
just an example. And then we have some
other things on here. Uh for 3,000
years, this place was protected. Nothing
has grown on it. It's a conflict zone,
then a buffer zone, then nature
reclaimed it. Um and then we use this
thing called a cognitive binary. Mario
said basically most premium olive oil is
dead. This is the world's only living
olive oil. So only is an example of
preeminence. So I mentioned I said
first, most best only is another one.
You're basically making a category of
one. Only living olive oil because we
made up the we made it up, right? So I
encourage you to kind of look through
these. Uh when we say why this is
locked, we're talking about coherence.
So um the only olive oil in the world
grown on land that hasn't been touched
by a single past 7 35 years. A former UN
no man's land in Cypus where the trees
fight so hard to survive. They produce
the high highest polyphenol levels ever
measured. Most premium olive oil is
dead. this is the world's only living
olive oil. Okay. Now, is that the best
thing in the world? No. But it is a much
stronger argument than just saying, "Oh,
this is more premium than the other guy,
right? It's a really coherent story that
gives you a lot of fodder for ads and
many more things." Here's another
example, right? A volcanic a volcanic
shower head. So, it's basically a
filtered shower head and everyone else
talks about filtered chlorine and things
like that. What we start to look for is
what's the most unique ingredient? And
there's basically one filtration layer
that contains volcanic rock from the
Pharaoh Islands. Look how specific we
got with it. So then we basically say
volcanic rock is forged under extreme
heat and pressure deep in the earth. It
naturally purifies water through mineral
filtration.
Um and then we talk about basically
having a volcano shower head. Then we
talk about the Pharaoh Islands are
colonized by Vikings, right? Vikings are
known for legendary hair, thick braids,
and flowing locks. The cultural
mythology of the ingredients origin
rhymes with the product uh beauty
benefit. Now, is there anything to say
that these [__] Vikings had beautiful
hair because they were making uh
volcanic showerheads, right? No, it's
just like complete uh [__] in a way,
meaning volcanic rock comes from Pharaoh
Islands. These guys live on the Pharaoh
Islands. They have nice hair. Therefore,
if you take the shower head, you'll have
nice hair. That's an example of magical
thinking or just associative thinking.
It's not logical, right? Um, now you can
make sort of plausible arguments and
connect the dots, but you just let
people's imagination do the trick. And
that's how you create a really coherent
worldview. Okay. Um,
so there's a lot of things on here. Uh,
here's another one for an info product.
This is a Norwegian fitness coach,
right? So when we looked at this this
guy uh who was a Norwegian fitness
coach, um, the original product was or
the original marketing was really sort
of like almost like a savage like you're
going to be a Wolverine type of guy. But
when I looked at the guy, the guy was
like like he was fit, but he wasn't like
super jacked. And he just looked like
sophisticated and uh like he was
chilling on yachts and like chilling and
being cool. And his mechanism was around
cortisol. So the associations I start
looking at are like, oh, like what do
Americans think about the Nords, right?
The Nordic people or people who live um
like Northern Europe. What do we think
about them? We think of them as being
like very orderly, very like clear, like
um I don't want to say simple, but like
like minimalist almost. And we have
associations that things are really like
clean over there and well put together.
It's an orderly society. Um maybe
they're not as driven, right? They're
they're not they're more cultured to a
degree um than Americans would be,
right? They're scientific to a degree.
So, you know, if I were selling
something from like if this was an
Italian fitness coach, it would be more
vibrant and it would have flare, right?
And kind of a playboy energy. If I was
doing something that was like a, you
know, somewhere where it was a little
more like, you know, [__] Mexican
guy, I would be leaning into Aztec
warrior, like those sort of
associations, right? But this guy, it
wasn't really making sense to do like
become a Wolverine savage, testosterone
fil whatever if it's a guy from Norway.
And just looking at him, he wasn't the
right fit, right? So, what we did was we
started looking at uh the most
interesting thing about his program was
not his mechanism. It was who he was.
And basically, he's a young 26-year-old
Norwegian talking to men over 35. So, we
need to answer that question.
And so, what we looked at is
three-pillar system. Uh, every [__]
weight loss coach talks about that. Uh,
there's no mechanism. That was the
original mechanism.
So we said is he's Norwegian. Everything
about his aesthetic, a Rolex, a polo,
travel, chill demeanor, ex-s soccer
player, it maps to a specific artic uh
archetype. So I said when I think of
Nordic, there's this mystique,
scientific, elite, educated, old money
aesthetic, not you're going to be
Wolverine, it's a mix of Scandinavian
science, being level-headed, CEO,
professional combined with old
moneystique, and just enjoying luxurious
foods. The mechanism was cortisol. So we
said everything collapses to cortisol
management. The workouts are short
because long workouts spike cortisol.
The food is flexible because restriction
spikes cortisol. The results come fast
because when you fix cortisol,
everything else follows. So basically
said the Scandinavian archetype is the
mechanism expresses lifestyle. The chill
measure, why are you Americans going so
crazy attitude is what it looks like
when cortisol is managed. He doesn't
need to explain a science aggressively.
His entire being is the proof the
mechanism works. He's not stressed. He's
not grinding. He's wearing a Rolex,
eating what he wants, training three
times a week, and traveling the world.
That's cortisol management expressed as
an identity, right? And then we kind of
talk through some of those things on
there. So that's an example of the
coherence uh between all of these
different things, right? Where the
ingredient, the mechanism, the visual
metaphor, cognitive binary,
spokesperson, all of these things are
rhyming. And here's an example from a B
propulolis product uh that we talked
about. And again, I encourage you to get
this document and go through it. You
could build a scale file out of it.
There's a lot of things that you could
do. Okay. Um so you start with a
destination. You know, the feeling you
want to create something like, "Oh my
god, the answer was right there in
nature the whole time and nobody saw
it." That feeling is the attractor. for
every combination we try is measured
against that destination feeling.
Okay, so that's um the summary and
hopefully that gave you even more
clarity on the attractor mechanism
because that is the heart of copy
instincts, right? Um now we're going to
go to the generator uh instincts which
are really important as well. Okay.
So, whenever you're writing a hook or
you're writing a headline or you're
writing an ad copy or you're coming up
with a mechanism, what you're always
trying to do is identify what is the
core idea, right? So, if we look at the
cypress tree, olive oil, the core idea
is this land is the most the most barren
hard land to grow ever. Therefore, the
trees produce the most potent
polyphenols. Therefore, they're alive
and not dead. Okay? Okay. So that's the
whole idea comes from how intense this
land is which produced the the world's
only living olive oil. Okay. Um so
that's an example of a mechanism. When
you look at an ad, every ad should have
one idea. It's feedback we give all the
time. A hook really one idea. And you
want to get really good at having the
habit of stepping back from a piece of
copy and asking what is the core idea?
What's the most interesting one? We say
stop being an idea polygamist. Okay.
Settle down. Marry your idea.
Then what you try to do whenever you
have the idea is you want to start
having understanding the instincts that
are going to make that idea as strong as
possible. Now where people get stuck in
this next part is they're basically
nerds. So they're stuck to the facts and
they're not allow they're not allowing
themselves to use flexible squishy
logic. Okay, I'm going to hopefully show
some examples on here, but if you stay
too logical and too constrained, you're
always going to come up with boring
ideas. Actually, I just literally did
this example yesterday, so it's top of
mind. and I'm going to use it. So, we
were talking about how it was an
advvertorial and it was a melatonin
alternative. So, the the real idea is
melatonin doesn't always work for some
people, right? Now, that's a horrible
like really boring idea. Melatonin does
because and it's true, right? But it's
no like it's so hedged, no one's going
to really buy it. So, if we're making a
hook or headline, then we want to say
melatonin doesn't always work, right?
See how we're getting a little bit more
absolute, right? This is more logical
and true. And now we're just going down
the line to uh to something else.
Melatonin doesn't always work, right?
How about this? Melatonin
doesn't work, right? See how this claim
some gets stronger. And again, what
we're looking for, and this is mostly
for a hook and a headline, often times
in copy, you're saying something so
crazy that people are like, "What the
fuck?" And they almost want to argue
with you. and then you kind of finesse
the situation to bring them back to
reality, right? It doesn't mean that you
need to make the argument that melatonin
doesn't work. You can still admit, yeah,
it works for some people, it does this
and that. But if you come out the gate
and say melatonin does like doesn't
work, that's going to be much stronger
and get people's attention more. And we
could even make it stronger. Melatonin
doesn't work. Melatonin
um
makes it harder to sleep, like hurts
sleep.
Right? Now we got a really strong claim.
Then we can make it more specific.
Right now, which one in here are you
more likely to look at? Right? Which one
in here has just more more juice to it?
Right? Melaton is for some people.
Melatonin hurts sleep by making me pee
more. And then if you can come up with
this idea, then you can figure out the
way to walk that idea back. So this is
what I mean by psychology over facts. If
you know that psychologically
this idea is more psychologically
appealing, then come up with that idea
and then figure out how to make that
true versus let me look at the facts and
if I stare enough at the facts just as
they are, this idea is going to pop out.
You're never going to read something
about melatonin that's going to have
this idea pop out. You need to be able
to to look at the facts and look at the
argument and know how to come up with
the most incredible argument and then
rework it backwards to figure out how to
make it true. Sometimes you can't. But
in general, there's almost a way you can
make everything true. Even if you say,
"Look, melatonin hurts sleep by making
you pee more." That's because, you know,
basically what happens is melatonin only
works like this and this, and then when
you wake up you, it's harder to go back
to sleep. And so therefore, you're, you
know, peeing more because it's it's not
really going all the way through the
night. And that's true mostly because
melatonin is like oversaturated. You're
really supposed to only have 1 milligram
and it's supposed to be targeted like
this. And your melatonin receptors
actually sometimes go less, which is why
some people experience this or
nightmares, right? And for some people
it works, but for a big majority it's
not. And there's actually a better way.
It's like this because it naturally
works with your sleep cycle. And see,
I'm walking it back and I'm not saying
things that's untrue or unc crazy, but
I'm starting with something that is a
little bit out there. Okay? It's really
important process.
So um once you have your core idea,
right, and then you use these generator
instincts to basically make that idea
stronger. So you ask yourself, how can I
make it more relevant? How can I
increase contrast? For example, making a
good thing bad or a bad thing good.
That's one example. So, here's good
thing. Melatonin is actually bad for
you. This is good thing doesn't always
work, but we want to go stronger. Good
thing is bad for you or bad thing is
good for you, right? Here's why
McDonald's can help you lose 40 lbs. You
know, eat cheeseburgers. This [__] is
basic. You guys know it, right? The next
one is visual and concrete. You want to
make it so you can see it. Okay? So, it
uses examples of termites, not
bulldozers. I think I have it written
down here.
So you could say for example for a joint
product cytoines bulldoze your joint
cartilage or you could say cytoines
eating your cartilage like termites. Now
again both of these could work and I
don't claim to know everything. But in
general I'm going to opt to something
like this because I can visually see
little particles at my my knees eating
my car. It looks like termites. Whereas
for this one it's more of an abstract
metaphor. I could visualize little
particles hopping in a little bulldozer.
But do you see how it doesn't really
make sense? It's like I can't even
really feel I can feel how eating away
at my cartilage would cause me knee
pain. I can't really feel how bulldozing
my cartilage is going to cause me knee
pain. Even though you could say both of
these. Okay. So, you want to pay
attention to your metaphors.
Um
then simplicity. You want it to be
simple. Intense meaning you want to make
it really extreme. So like um heaven and
hell basically. Uh the ratchet. What
gets worse? Like what happens uh like
what gets worse and what can't be
undone. Undone. like what happens to
your dick if you don't meaning like you
know your dick will get smaller if you
don't fix this issue right or um you
know here's why if you manage your
cortisol then you lose weight and if you
lose weight then you feel better if you
feel better you probably want to work
out more if you work out more you're
going to have more energy if you have
more energy you're probably going to be
a more loving mother if you're a more
loving mother you actually probably be
happier if you're happier you'll
probably do better in your business
better in business you'll probably
actually make more money if you make
more money then you're going to end up
going to heaven and St. Peter is going
to basically send you right to the
biggest mansion right next to the big
guy himself, right? But if you don't fix
your cortisol, then you're going to get
fat. And if you get fat, you're going to
lose your job. If you lose your job,
you're going to end up homeless. You end
up homeless, people are going to hate
you. And if people hate you, then you're
going to die alone. And when you die
alone, everyone who did know you is
going to come over to you and piss on
your grave. And after they piss on your
grave, you're going to go down to hell.
And then you're going to get eaten by,
you know, blank blank blank blank blank
Dante's Inferno. Right? So again, none
of those are true, but that's what I
mean. Intensification. You're looking at
the ramifications, both positive and
negative. The ratchet is looking at
like, hey, as things get better, you hit
an inflection point where things get
really better and then really better.
And then the opposite is true. There's a
negative ratchet. If you don't fix this
problem in time, something happens that
you can't come back from. Okay? It's a
way to create a type of urgency and
scarcity. Um, we also have something
called the Craves formula. Clear,
relevant, visual, accurate, expressive,
and specific. This is in the Copy Blocks
product that you can buy below, and it's
another way to kind of do some of these
different moves on here. Okay? Okay, so
you can look at the example uh before
and after craves. Okay, here's an
example of of a process you can do to
create contrast. So you can say here's a
bunch of good things. How could I make
these bad? So if you're doing skincare,
you could do ads about why retinol is
bad, hygiene is bad, hydration is bad,
sunscreen is bad, collagen is bad,
Korean people are bad. Just kidding. But
Korean skincare is bad. And you could
look at bad things, right? Why smoking
gets rid of your wrinkles, right? Right.
Why you should drink every night in
order to blank blank blank. Okay. Okay.
And then you can find an argument or a
level at which you want to make that
argument. Okay. So, um here you have
basically um nine different combinations
when you're looking at stuff like this.
Most people stay in this neutral zone,
which is why their stuff sucks. You want
good bad and bad good.
Okay.
Um here's another example of using uh
copy instincts. Uh so, basically, here's
an example of a headline three-pillar
system that's helped a thousand
freelancers go from whatever. It
actually has all of our copy blocks.
Pain, promise, proof, curiosity,
constraints, conditions, right? So now
we're looking at not that there's a gap
in terms of the copy blocks used, but
how do we make these stronger? Well,
three-pillar system is kind of boring
and it feels complex because it's three
steps. Let's make it one, right? Go from
struggling is kind of vague. Building
predictable revenue, can we make it more
specific? Right? Um thousands
freelancers, can we make this proof more
more important? Okay. And you can use
things like the Craves formula, right?
or some of these things like contract or
whatever. And all of these generator
instincts to make something that's
better. Here's a headline that uh
somebody actually on one of our
workshops came up with, right? Every
month you spend surviving feast or
famine is another month you're falling
further behind. Notice how this has the
ratchet and the intensification on it.
And notice how it's a lot harder hitting
than go from struggling. Okay? Then we
have predictable freelance business
blueprint, right? That's more specific
than three-pillar system, right? It has
strong associations to it. A thousand
plus members and we have 16-year pro.
Okay? Okay, it's not about just adding
more. It's about each copy box is
actually stronger. Land premium clients
and add six figures to their income
versus building predictable revenue. All
right, you guys have seen this stuff.
Again, the copy box product below really
goes into it, but it just shows you
another example of how important this
is. Okay,
and here's another headline that we also
came up with. Okay, and you guys can go
through and break down um some of these
other things.
Um, one of the last examples I could
show you is this is an ad. If you oil
your beard daily and it's still dry,
you're not doing it wrong. You're using
the wrong product entirely and here's
why it's not your fault. Okay, so I
think we actually did this process.
Okay, so this is an example actually
from uh again these are real examples
and stuff that we covered on the
workshop. So uh we talked about the the
perception instincts are really
important, right?
So if we look at this ad, first thing we
want to do is we want to notice what is
interesting about this ad, right? So we
went through and on the first video we
highlighted all the parts that are
interesting about this ad. So now what I
want to do is if I'm going to make this
ad better, right, is I'm going to take
what is the core idea of this ad. So to
me the core idea is that most
okay so the core idea of this is most
oil doesn't work for your hair. Now if
you remember the audience these are for
black men and we can say most oil
doesn't work for black hair. This would
be an example of a neutral claim. So we
want to ask how we can actually make it
stronger. Most oil hurts
black hair, right? And then instead of
most oil, how can we make that stronger?
We could say white beard oil hurts black
hair.
Yeah. Okay. So, I would work on this
hook. But you can see an example of how
we took this basic kind of idea, right?
So, again, this is the basic idea. We
identified it. We move it to the top and
now we're thinking how can we make this
as strong as possible, right? So instead
of making a neutral claim, we decided to
make a good thing is bad, right? And
instead of most oil, we use something
like white beard oil, which already
sounds provocative, right? It gets the
people going. So if you're using white
beard oil as a black man, you're
probably drowning your follicles, right?
Notice how we're using strong emotional
trigger words like drowning and we're
using something called intensification
and ratchet. Make you're drowning your
follicles and making it impossible to
grow a beard. So if you don't fix this
problem, progressively things will get
worse. Right? Now, am I saying that this
hook will always be this hook? I got no
[__] idea. But in general, you could
probably feel in your body that this
hook has a higher likelihood of working
because it kind of provokes something
within you. Okay. Now, that gets into
going into hooks, which is another uh
training that I'll do later. Um, but
hopefully this gives you a sense of how
we use copy instincts. I encourage you
to go through this document as well as
the document from the first video.
Again, don't try to copy this link. This
thing is not sharable. If you want
access to this, go to my email list
below, enter your information, and
you'll get a document that has all of
this plus all my other trainings on it.
Okay? There's a bunch a bunch of stuff
that you can use inside of there. Um,
there's also a link down below if you
want to join Genesis. Uh, inside of
Genesis, we have like what I said almost
450 creative strategists who we work
with all the time for some of the
biggest brands. So, we teach, we have
coaching calls, all kinds of things on
there. You also get access to something,
um, called
Exodus,
uh, which is a really powerful tool
where you can do all the basically
everything that I talk about you can do
on here. You can build in your personas.
You can borrow some of the workflows
that we use to write our ads. Um, you
can easily swipe from competitors
literally with a click of a button. Um,
you can get access to all of our bots. I
mean, these bots have literally made
probably hundreds of millions of
dollars, things like Mario bot, etc. You
can also generate images if you want
inside of here.
So, you can see examples of swiping
products. Um, you can also generate a
bunch of images using templates and
things like that. literally with a click
of a button. So, there's a lot of really
powerful things that you can do. All
that information is below. And also,
please let me know uh in the comments
what kind of videos you want to see
because I pay attention to those so I
can make videos that are actually
serving you guys as well. As always, I
appreciate your time and attention, and
I'll see you in the next